el primer ataque de rayos láser de la
historia se produjo el 4 de agosto del
año 2019 os lo digo en serio y no no me
he vuelto loco
los rayos láser existen y ya se han
utilizado en combate
concretamente hablamos del derribo de un
drone de combate en la guerra de siria
el drone por cierto pertenecía a los
rebeldes sirios y la pregunta es quién
creéis que disparó el rayo láser qué
país puede estar tan avanzado como para
tener armas láser listas para usarlas
muchos pensaréis en eeuu
o tal vez china o tal vez rusia pues
atentos el primer país en usar rayos
láser en la historia de la humanidad ha
sido turquía a estas alturas supongo que
ya os habrá estallado la cabeza como es
posible que existan los rayos láser y
cómo es posible que que turquía los
tenga antes que ningún otro país desde
cuando turquía es un líder tecnológico y
cómo funcionan los rayos láser
tranquilos en este vídeo os lo vamos a
explicar con todo lujo de detalles
vamos con ello
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la pregunta que todos nos hacemos a
estas alturas es quién necesita netflix
teniendo el año 2020 si no fuera porque
todo lo que os contamos es real
pensarías que aquí en visual polític nos
ha poseído mundo desconocido este año
hemos visto ya la pandemia del nuevo
shark coronavirus 2 la toma de hong kong
por parte de china y hasta a bruce
willis vestido de doraemon
costa vuelve por si todo esto no fuera
suficiente ahora os traemos rayos láser
los hemos visto en millones de películas
pero ahora ya son una realidad y muchos
pensaréis vale aparte de para molar qué
ventaja tienen los rayos láser sobre
vamos a decir un misil normal y
corriente de los de toda la vida pues
muchas básicamente un rayo láser viaja a
la velocidad de la luz lo que significa
que es prácticamente imposible esquivar
es la definición perfecta de donde pongo
el ojo pongo la barra de hecho gracias a
los rayos láser turquía ha podido
derribar un dron en movimiento con
precisión milimétrica y diréis pero cómo
funcionan los rayos láser pues para eso
vamos a tener que hablar mucho de física
cuántica y por eso tenemos a nuestro
experto en la materia el señor javier
santaolaya de date un blog hola hijos de
einstein si en este vídeo vamos a tener
que hablar mucho de ciencia y creedme os
va a estallar la cabeza pero antes de
hablar de ciencia tenemos que hablar de
política porque si amigos de visual
política turquía es algo así como el
malote de la otan
es decir si la otan fuera el clásico
instituto de una película de los años 80
turquía sería el macarrilla de la clase
el que se busca peleas contornos por
ejemplo turquía se lleva fatal con
grecia que también es miembro de la otan
y eeuu que siguiendo la metáfora sería
el capitán del equipo de fútbol
americano no vende armas a turquía y
como los turcos no pueden comprar armas
a eeuu que creéis que hacen pues esto
y ya dice que compró los misiles s 400
rusos para usarlos no para ponerlos a un
lado puede parecer una tontería pero
esta noticia es muy importante a fin de
cuentas rusia es el antagonista de la
otan y turquía que es miembro de la otan
les está comprando armamento todo esto
explica que cuando entrevistamos al
secretario general de la otan
jens stoltenberg le preguntáramos por
esto
los costos disney
por supuesto estos nuevos sistemas de
defensa aérea s 400 son rusos y estarán
integrados en el sistema integral de
defensa aérea de la otan estando lo que
estaban por su cuenta fuera del sistema
de defensa aérea de la otan pero no sólo
eso turquía es uno de los países que más
dinero gasta en ejército de hecho
después de eeuu son el ejército más
grande de la otan al menos en lo que a
número de soldados respecta por supuesto
cuando hablamos de defensa los soldados
no lo son todo es más cada vez es más
importante la tecnología y el armamento
y ahí turquía nunca ha sido un país
entero pensad que hablamos de un país
que aunque tenga 80 millones de
habitantes tiene el pib de los países
bajos y por eso es tan sorprendente que
hayan sido los pioneros en utilizar
rayos láser como es posible porque
turquía tiene rayos láser y cómo
funcionan hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
[Música]
antes de seguir quiero que le echéis un
vistazo a este mapa esto es el estrecho
del bósforo y pertenece a turquía sin
embargo este estrecho si os dais cuenta
es la única salida al mediterráneo que
podría tener rusia durante siglos rusia
ha querido controlarlo y turquía no le
deja a ambos países desconocen el
significado de la palabra diplomacia y
todo esto explica que rusia y turquía
sean enemigos íntimos desde la noche de
los tiempos
y todo esto qué consecuencias tiene en
la política internacional pues en época
de guerra fría significaba muchísimo
básicamente turquía era el país más anti
soviético del mundo y por eso en el año
1952 entraron en la otan haciendo
cuentas la otan es una alianza militar
que nació para defenderse de la unión
soviética y turquía tenía un ejército
muy grande y con credenciales anti
soviéticas y anticomunistas de sobra
para que les recibieran con los brazos
abiertos
[Música]
el problema pues que como decíamos antes
turquía es el malote de la clase y se
lleva mal con todo el mundo pensando
bien turquía tiene un pasado imperial
durante siglos fueron el imperio otomano
y dominaron un enorme territorio que
cubría todo áfrica del norte este pasado
imperial ha dejado muchos muertos en el
armario que incluyen un genocidio contra
los armenios problemas con la minoría
kurda y un conflicto con grecia por la
isla de chipre y diréis pero de verdad
esto es un problema pues lo cierto es
que si en el año 1974 turquía invadió la
isla de chipre desde entonces esta isla
está dividida por una de las fronteras
más militarizadas del mundo en dos
mitades en una se habla turco y en la
otra se habla griego
podéis imaginar gracia que también es
miembro de la otan se lleva fatal con
turquía y todo esto explica que en los
años 70 eeuu le dijera a turquía vale
vamos a ver mira turquía nosotros te
vamos a proteger pero como no lo
hacíamos de ti porque vas de malote por
la vida no te vamos a vender armas que
sabe dios lo que vas a ver con ellas
igual te dejamos unos misiles y nos
bombardea las gracias y amigos de visual
político turquía es aliado de eeuu pero
a duras penas les puede comprar armas y
cuál creéis que ha sido su respuesta
pues decir a qué no me vendes armas pues
te vas a enterar voy a montar mi propia
industria armamentística con misiles y
con cañones y con cañones lanza misiles
del tamaño de un dinosaurio te vas a
enterar de lo que somos capaces los
turcos
el problema pues contestado a esta
pregunta habéis oído hablar alguna vez
de un silicon valley turco yo tampoco
conclusión que durante décadas lo más
destacable que tuvieron fueron los
llamados lanzamisiles o varias que por
supuesto son los más grandes del mundo
año de un dinosaurio
[Música]
[Aplausos]
de eso nadie ha dicho nunca o tecnología
militar turca a medias de hecho en los
años 2000 el gobierno de ankara empezó a
dejar de lado todos estos programas
militares que no iban a ningún sitio a
fin de cuentas para que querían tantas
armas si ya estaban protegidos por la
otan curiosamente estos fueron los
mejores años de turquía cuando empezaron
a crecer de verdad incluso se llegó a
discutir si podían entrar en la unión
europea pero todo eso cambió en el año
2016 y diréis qué pasó en el año 2016
jueces
pagarán un alto precio por su traición
los soldados turcos se rinden en el
puente del bósforo tras un golpe de
estado fallido que ha terminado con 250
muertos
erdogán jura venganza exacto hablamos
del golpe de estado contra el presidente
de turquía recep tayip erdogán ese golpe
de estado que por cierto muchos creen
que en el fondo fue un autogolpe una
excusa perfecta para cambiar la
constitución del país y tener más poder
autogolpe un autogolpe lo cierto es que
desde entonces el nuevo objetivo de
erdogán es el regreso del imperio
otomano volver a controlar el norte de
áfrica que el mundo entero tenga miedo
del ejército turco y a la vez que el
ejército turco tenga miedo de erdogán
porque para eso tomó medidas como éste
el ejército y el poder judicial tras un
golpe de estado fallido es lo que tienen
los líderes autoritarios que normalmente
no se fían de su ejército porque les
puede dar un golpe de estado para que os
hagáis una idea tras esta purga militar
quedaron solo 20 pilotos de combate
pensarlo bien
turquía tiene 200 cazas de combate pero
solo 20 personas que lo pueden pilotar y
algo parecido pasa con el resto de
divisiones del ejército básicamente al
quitar a todas las facciones que podrían
en algún momento estar en su contra
erdogán se ha quedado con un ejército
esclerótico y os preguntaréis vamos a
ver cómo vas a expandir un nuevo imperio
otomano
si no tienes soldados pues erdogán ha
aprobado a comprar armas a estados
unidos'
y adquiere los misiles patriot de eeuu
para disuadir a rusia en siria y como os
podéis imaginar eeuu le ha dicho otra
vez erdogán chavalote tu para qué
quieres esos misiles patriot o sea a
quien quieren matar tú con eso no
querrás matar tú a kurdos que te vea las
intenciones erdogán que tú a los kurdos
pues como que no que tú los derechos
humanos los consideras opcionales anda
anda misiles patrones quieres y amigos
de visual político lejos de llevarse
bien con erdogán donald trump ha puesto
nuevas sanciones económicas a turquía y
porque os preguntaréis pues por castigo
a los maltratos que han perpetrado a la
minoría kurda minoría que por otra parte
es aliada de estados unidos
para que os hagáis una idea los kurdos
han sido fundamentales en la lucha
contra el daes así que trump no va a
vender armamento a turquía para que
ataquen a sus propios aliados como os
decía turquía sigue siendo el malote de
la otan sí vale nos llevamos bien con él
jugamos con él a la pelota pero nos
interesa tenerle controlado así que de
nuevo la otan sigue protegiendo turquía
pero no quiere que tenga su propio
armamento y esto explica noticias como
esta compañía extiende el despliegue de
sistemas de misiles antiaéreos en
turquía
en otras palabras españa es aliada de
estados unidos y tiene misiles patriot
la otan les ha dicho que pongan unos
pocos para proteger la frontera de
turquía con irán pero ya está y como os
podéis imaginar esto no le hace ninguna
gracia a erdogán él quiere tener su
propio armamento y su propia doctrina
militar de hecho turquía está presente
en la guerra de libia y tienen sus
propias alianzas y su propia estrategia
totalmente al margen de la otra como os
podéis imaginar para eso necesitan
armamento así que como eeuu continúa con
su política
de no venderles armas turquía ha vuelto
a decir que sigue sin venderme armas
pues te vas a enterar porque voy a
montar otra nueva industria
armamentística esta vez con con rayos
láser hombre te vas a enterar de lo que
somos capaces los trucos y así es como
turquía ha reabierto sus programas de
desarrollo de industria militar nacional
y por supuesto entre todos esos
programas se incluye este
[Música]
y crea un sistema de armas láser para
reforzar su ejército es más este paso yo
creo que terminará entrenando tiburones
para montarle rayos láser en la cabeza
los tiburones a fin de cuentas dan miedo
y no dan golpes de estado es decir que
son los soldados perfectos para erdogán
pensando bien los rayos láser tienen
muchas ventajas son una tecnología muy
prometedora para defenderse de ataques
antiaéreos y para operar los hace falta
nuevo personal militar es decir que
erdogán tiene la excusa perfecta para
contratar a nuevos soldados que les sean
leales a él pero la pregunta es qué son
los rayos láser para qué sirven y cómo
funcionan pues esto nos lo va a explicar
nada más y nada menos que javier
santaolaya atentos
[Música]
rayos láser la nueva pólvora en su día
la invención de la pólvora cambió la
forma de hacer la guerra harán lo mismo
los rayos láser cómo funcionan bien en
usos civiles y date que te lo cuente
[Música]
pues estamos hablando de uno de los
inventos más importantes del siglo tanto
que son hasta la fecha cinco los premios
nobel otorgados por su desarrollo y sus
aplicaciones desde 1964 y aplicaciones a
hiper un chorro muchísimas desde
electores de códigos de barra en
metalurgia en medicina en óptica o
incluso para apuntar al portero de
fútbol rival si es que tienes muy mala
leche y por supuesto si lo has adivinado
también sirve para hacer la guerra y
esto es por sus características tan
especiales con las que vas a flipar y
detrás de las que no está cualquier
hombre posiblemente hablamos del físico
más importante de todos los tiempos
albert einsten y prepara bien la cabeza
porque encima está involucrada en la
mecánica cuántica pero vayamos al grano
hablemos de enlace que es el láser
fuesen láseres luz luz normal y
corriente sí sí como la luz del sol o la
de la bombilla del baño de tu casa pero
claro yo sé que tú no estás
suficientemente loco o loca para
intentar derribar un dron con la luz de
la bombilla del baño porque no tiene
ningún sentido si el láser en naturaleza
se parece y mucho
a la luz de la bombilla pero tiene
ciertas particularidades que la hacen
muy especial en física y que es el
lenguaje que hablamos los físicos
diríamos que es luz coherente
monocromática y muy focalizada
y porque que cuaja desde el cuerpo pues
vamos paso por paso para que nos dé
piernas monocromática quiere decir que
es luz de una única frecuencia de un
único color de todos los posibles
colores que puede tener un tipo de luz
esta es perfectamente ajustada para que
sea sólo de un tipo focalizada quiere
decir que es luz que no se dispersa
normalmente la luz lo que hace es
distribuirse por todo el espacio se
difumina con lo cual la energía se va
perdiendo con el cuadrado de la
distancia la luz láser en cambio es muy
dirigida y finalmente coherente esta es
una propiedad quizás un poco más difícil
de imaginar pero sabiendo que la luz son
ondas podemos decir que un tipo de luz
es muy coherente si todas marchan a la
par al mismo ritmo de forma coherente no
están en desfase una sub y la otra baja
no todas van a lunismo
[Música]
en resumen podemos decir que el láser es
un tipo de luz donde las partículas los
fotones son muy ordenados así quizás la
mejor forma de entender la diferencia
entre la luz normal de una linterna y
una luz láser es compararlo con un
ejército la luz de la linterna sería
como el ejército del 'botellón'
imagínate algo así como el ejército de
curro jiménez un auténtico descalabro un
auténtico desastre
el láser en cambio habría que imaginarlo
como soldados perfectamente formados
alineados marchando en orden síncronos
como vendría a ser un ejército de clones
de starwars
y esto es gracias a las propiedades
cuánticas de la materia y en particular
a la estructura en capa de los átomos
algo que sólo se pudo entender con la
llegada de la mecánica cuántica einstein
fue suficientemente hábil para ver en
esta nueva concepción de los átomos esta
interesante aplicación sólo pudo hacerse
realidad con el paso de las décadas una
vez
ella nos hubo dejado hablamos de los
años 60 por estas propiedades en el
hacer es capaz de concentrar muchísima
energía en poco espacio y en pulsos
también de muy poca duración piensen que
para las aplicaciones lo que importa no
es tanto la energía sino la potencia
cuánto eres capaz de concentrar esa
energía en el tiempo y en el espacio
piénsalo tú seguramente te dejarías
aplicar una pequeña descarga prolongada
durante días no tenían nada pequeñas
cosquillas en la piel ahora imagínate si
concentradas toda esa energía en un
pulso de un segundo sería como
enchufarte a una torre de electricidad y
eso creo que nos sienta bien a ninguno
lo importante no es la cantidad total de
energía sino como éstas se distribuyen
en el espacio y en el tiempo su
concentración su potencia con los nuevos
desarrollos se ha conseguido multiplicar
el efecto es común al de la luz láser
elevando su potencia a órdenes de 10
elevado a 23 vatios por centímetro
cuadrado y esto es una auténtica
barbaridad y esto es gracias a un
invento revolucionario relativo enlace
que introdujeron muy strickland
ganadores del premio nobel de hace tan
sólo una
con un láser de alta potencia como este
bien puedes derivar un dron desviar un
misil o enviar una nave a alfa centauri
porque también hay aplicaciones civiles
interesantes si se aplicaciones de todo
tipo y conecto amigos y amigas estamos
entrando en una nueva era la era del
láser de alta potencia que tiemble obi
wan pero como os podéis imaginar turquía
no es el único país en tener rayos láser
son los primeros en haberlos probado en
un caso de combate real pero eeuu ya
tiene sus propias armas láser sin ir más
lejos en mayo de 2020 mientras todos
estábamos confinados en casa la marina
de eeuu ya hizo su primera prueba de un
rayo láser a bordo de un barco
china también está haciendo sus propias
investigaciones así que la pregunta
ahora es para vosotros creéis que
estamos ante una nueva forma de hacer la
guerra hasta qué punto los rayos láser
terminarán sustituyendo a los misiles
las balas y los fusiles y lo que es más
importante terminar a turquía teniendo
su nuevo imperio otomano podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a visual política y dadle a
la campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones y tampoco
olvidéis suscribiros a date un blog
donde el señor javier santa olalla os
enseñará un montón de cosas sobre
ciencia que harán que alguno le estalle
la cabeza si os ha gustado este vídeo
dadle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]